I am going to the dermatologist did you
notice I've got like crazy puffy eyes I
did not notice that I thought you were
just kind of sleepy I got a rash and
I've been taking a ton of Benadryl and I
was hoping it'd be better this morning
it's not it's worse tell them what it's
from at least I don't know what it's
from but it might be from eating beef
burger shut the [__] up it's I swear to
God it's all I ate yesterday and I
started developing it last night oh my
Lord that was two days ago now obviously
I don't know
and I could I could never say that Beast
Burger gave me a rash but I think Beast
Burger gave me a wrap which one which
Burger I got everything you got
everything taste test what are the what
are the Beast Burger Burgers like was it
was it the Dream Burger like who who
which content creator specifically gave
you the rash you think it was Mr Beast
for sure yeah it was a Mr Beast one oh
no no it was it anyway so let's so
anyway let's move on